Also wir haben ein Problem mit SSL. Und zwar gibt es das alte von Netscape erfundene SSL. Und das von der ITF abgesegnete TLS. Eigentlich möchte man nur noch TLS haben, am besten in einer möglichst hohen Version. Es gibt aber aus Kompatibilitätsgründen und anderen unschönen Dingen immer noch sehr viele, die dieses SSLv3 angeknipst haben. Und das Problem ist jetzt, ohne jetzt weiter ins Detail gehen zu wollen, SSLv3 ist kaputt. Und was leider Browser irgendwie machen, ist irgendwie, man kann die Browser dazu zwingen, weil es kein sauberes Downgrade gibt, kann man ihnen sagen, ich kann aber kein TLS, ich downgrade jetzt mal auf SSLv3. Und dann sagen die, ja, ist okay, super. Oder halt auch End-User-Software.
Lass mich versuchen, das zusammenzufassen. Jeder Browser spricht zwei verschiedene Arten von verschlüsselter Webverbindung. Also vielleicht noch mehrere, aber zwei verschiedene. Es gibt eine neue, die ist gut. Es gibt eine schlechte, die ist kaputt. Und es gibt jetzt eine Möglichkeit, dem Browser zu sagen, du, ich kann die neue nicht, nimm mal bitte die alte. Und dann sagt der Browser, okay, mach ich. Und dann kann ich sozusagen rein, weil die alte erstellt ist.
Zumindest gibt es starke Anzeichen, dass es sehr, sehr einfach wird. Und ganz klare Handlungsanweisung ausmachen. SSLv3 ausmachen. Es gibt da Workarounds, die vorgeschlagen sind, die allerdings die Standardisierung bis heute nicht geschafft haben.
Ich glaube, bei Heise gibt es sozusagen so eine Anleitung, zum selber nachklicken, wie man bei dem jeweiligen Browser... Genau. Vielleicht ist das ja auch in Showdots.
Im aktuellen Chrome ist es schon aus. Und Mozilla stellt für Firefox ein Plugin zur Verfügung, was es ausmacht. Einfach runterladen oder Chrome updaten.
Und in Explorer ist, glaube ich, auch heute oder gestern was rausgekommen.
Ja, den einfach nicht benutzen.
Aber interessant ist noch, dass dieses Feature, womit man das umgehen kann, dieser Standard dann noch nicht durch ist, dass der auch von zwei Google-Jungs ist. Und sind auch die gleiche oder zumindest einer davon, der den Puddel-Bug mit entdeckt hat. Also es ist schon alles eine Ecke da.
Ah ja, sehr gut.
Schon verdächtig.
Schauen wir mal, was da noch passiert.
Ja, das Puddel-Skype, genau.
So, dann gibt es eine schöne Sache, eine Geschichte mit einem Handy, einem Sony-Handy. Was ist da los?
Ja, man hat rausgefunden, dass die Sony Xperia-Telefone, die meisten davon, mit einer Backdoor ausgeliefert wurden, ab Werk. Das heißt, ich pack das aus und es ist eine Backdoor da drauf. Und diese funkt nach Beijing und sendet alles, was du auf deinem Telefon machst, dorthin, was umso brisanter ist, weil Sony ein japanisches Unternehmen ist.
Ups, haben die da schon was zu gesagt oder ist es so frisch, dass Sony immer noch überlegt, welchen Pressesprecher es jetzt nach vorne schickt?
Nach letztem Stand hat Sony noch nichts dazu gesagt.
Wir bleiben dran. So, die letzte Meldung, da geht es um FTDI. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, man lädt sich per Windows ein Update für einen Treiber eines Geräts herunter und dann ist das Gerät kaputt. Was ist da passiert?
FTDI baut unter anderem Chips, die man braucht, um mit seriellen Schnittstellen zu reden. Das hat so Fan Mirko vorhin schon sehr viel erzählt. Da diese Chips von FTDI sehr beliebt sind, haben sich findige Chinesen überlegt, wir bauen diese Chips einfach nach und verkaufen sie ein paar Euro billiger. Das fand FTDI doof und hat deswegen in ihrem neuen Treiberupdate eine Funktion eingebaut, was gefälschte Chips erkennt und diese dann unbrauchbar macht. Also nicht permanent, man kann das meistens reparieren, aber der Laie steht dann da erst mal mit einem kaputten Gerät und weiß im Zweifel ja auch gar nicht, dass er einen gefälschten Chip in seinem Gerät hat, weil er das Gerät irgendwie als schwarze Kiste gekauft hat.
Das konnte man nicht wissen.
Naja, also der Preisunterschied zwischen dem Original und dem gefälschten Chip liegt im Cent-Bereich. Also ich glaube, da kannst du auf den Preis vom Gerät nicht zurückschließen.
Wie laut reden, das ging vorher noch besser. Jetzt weiß ich noch nicht, was ich sagen wollte.
Okay, also wir lassen uns jetzt schon bei der News-Meldung bewenden, dass sozusagen der Driver das kaputt gemacht hat. Ich glaube, dieses Selbstjustiz eines Herstellers ist nochmal ein spannender Zugang.
Also er ist nicht hardwaremäßig kaputt. Er ist nur so umgeflasht, dass man ihn unter Windows nicht mehr benutzen kann.
Also ich glaube, für viele Leute kommt das selber raus. Und vielleicht können wir das bei anderer Gelegenheit nochmal genauer diskutieren.
Also vielleicht noch ganz abschließend. Der Treiber ist jetzt wieder aus dem Windows Update raus. Und man ist jetzt, wenn man den jetzt drunter lädt, wieder sicher.
Also Windows, also Microsoft fand das auch nicht so prall, dass sich der Hersteller irgendwie dazu gerufen gefühlt hat, über das Windows Update diese Backdoor praktisch oder was auch immer einzuführen.
Aber geht der neue Treiber auch, der jetzt rausgekommen ist, geht der auch mit den Clown-After-The-E-Chips oder tut er trotzdem einfach nicht mehr damit?
Ich kenne keinen, der sowas unter Windows benutzt.
So viel zu den Nerd-News hier im Chaosradio 206, wo wir über Hardwarehacking reden, wo wir schon gelernt haben, warum man das macht, was man damit alles anstellen kann. Fahrräder, 10.000 Volt Spitzen, das wird mich nicht los, das finde ich total großartig. Oder blinkende Lichter an Router dran basteln oder sogar Steckdosen damit fernsteuern. All das geht. Wir haben auch schon über die Werkzeuge gesprochen. Also wir haben festgestellt, manchmal braucht man wirklich ein Hammer, das ist der selten. Lötkolben den Umgang zu lernen, ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee. Und wir haben gelernt, was ein Multimeter, heißt es so? Multimeter, was ein Multimeter macht und wofür man ein Oszilloskop benutzen kann. Und da fiel schon in der letzten halben Stunde, die Hörer, die schon länger dabei sind, haben es vielleicht gehört, oft der Begriff Logic Analyzer. So, ein Oszilloskop misst also Wellenformen. Was macht ein Logic Analyzer?
Ein Logic Analyzer unterscheidet nur zwischen den Eins und Nullen, die über die Datenleitung gehen. Und da man in der digitalen Welt nicht mehr braucht, also man hat da keine großen Spannungsschwankungen, sondern halt nur die 5 Volt und die 0 Volt zum Beispiel, die Einsen und Nullen repräsentieren, kann man mit einem Logic Analyzer Einsen und Nullen aufnehmen und dann kann findiges Software daraus einen Datenstrom basteln und dir sagen, dass da das serielle Protokoll drüber gesprochen wird, dass zum Beispiel SPI drüber gesprochen wird, in welcher Frequenz der Daten gesendet werden und vieles mehr.
Also ich dachte jetzt erst, okay, das ist halt einfach nur ein billiges Osteoskop, was sozusagen nur die Spitzenmester, aber das ist, da geht es tatsächlich eher schon um die konkrete Analyse des Signals.
Also eigentlich ist es ein, also Hardware-mäßig ist es ein billiges Osteoskop. Und das Rest, der Rest ist dann halt wieder ein Software. Also du guckst dann halt, wie gesagt, du siehst halt die Einsen und Nullen und das Tolle an der Software, also an dieser Logic Analyzer Software, ist dann, dass es zum Beispiel auch sagen kann, das sind jetzt acht Klicks hintereinander, das heißt, diese acht Bits, fassen wir mal zu einem Byte zusammen, zeigen dir den Wert von diesem Byte an und können dir im Zweifelsfall dann auch die ASCII-Repräsentation davon anzeigen, also sagen, was da tatsächlich gerade an Werten über diese Leitung übertragen wurde.
Also ist das so ein Ding, was bekannte Protokolle sozusagen erkennt oder kann man damit auch völlig unbekannte Dinge analysieren?
Also die Grundlegende, was es halt dir anzeigt, sind die Einsen und Nullen. Alles andere ist dann halt Software-Frage, wenn du weißt, wie dieses Protokoll implementiert ist, weißt du halt, eine zwei Millisekunden lange Hochflanke folgt einer vier Millisekunden nicht-Hochflanke und es ist dann eine Eins oder so was. Und dann kannst du halt dann beliebig weiter dich nach oben in der Schicht, im Schichtmodell halt hangeln.
Und wenn du richtig gut bist, dann kannst du ja auch deinen eigenen Protokoll-Analyser schreiben. Wenn du vielleicht ein proprietäres Protokoll hast oder bei irgendeiner Firma arbeitest, dann schreibst du gleich deinen eigenen Analyzer und vielleicht schreibst du dann sogar zuerst den Software, um danach irgendwie dann zu checken, ob die Hardware, die dann produziert wurde, auch so funktioniert, wie du wolltest.
Genau, also wenn du nicht weißt, also wenn das Gerät, die Software es für dich nicht dekodieren kann, kannst du dir quasi aus deinem Logic Analyzer Tool das alles exportieren lassen und dann mit der Programmiersprache deiner Wahl da so lange draufhauen, bis die Daten für dich sind ergeben.
Da war wieder der Hammer. Ganz wichtiges Tool. Ich hab das Gefühl, bis zum Osterdaskob bin ich noch so hinterhergekommen. Was Mirko erzählt hat, ich zeig dann irgendwie so Wellenformen auf und kann da so grobe Fehler erkennen. Das ist doch jetzt mit dem Logic Analyzer schon durchaus der Punkt, wo man richtig programmieren können muss. Also wo man ganz tief, ne, da wird der Kopf geschüttelt.
Du kannst programmieren und den Protokollanalyzer schreiben, aber du musst ja nicht, wenn du Glück hast, dann sind da schon ganz viele dabei. Also zum Beispiel für die Serielle, da ist schon einer dabei. Und der erkennt dann, wenn es gut ist, dann erkennt er für dich, ob es irgendwie 8N1 ist oder 8E2 oder mit Parity oder ohne. Wenn du noch die Serielle von früher kennst, dann war es immer 8N1. Von so Modem, hast du mal Modem benutzt früher?
Es geht unter anderem darum, wie der Anfang und das Ende von diesen Bits dargestellt werden, also Start und Stop Bits. Also das N steht dann für No Parity.
Man kann ja die Signale rauslesen, aber was macht man dann damit?
Die Signale, da stehen ja deine Daten drin. Also wenn du zum Beispiel eine ganz normale Verbindung hast, stell dir vor, du warst früher mit so einem Modem in so einer Mailbox oder so einer, wie das doch, wie das Mailbox.
Lass doch mal lieber Mirko mit der Steckdose. Da kann man wieder als gutes Beispiel zum Beispiel nehmen.
Ich würde erstmal mit einer LED anfangen. Also nehmen wir den GPIO, der irgendwie auf Null gesetzt ist, also keine Spannung. Und jetzt schalte ich den an und er ist auf 5 Volt. Und ich da jetzt einen Logic Analyzer ranhänge, dann hätte ich die ganze Zeit Nullen gesehen und auf einmal sehe ich da eine Eins. Und wenn ich den GPIO jetzt wieder ausschalte und wieder einschalte und wieder einschalte dann sehe ich in dem Logic Analyzer so 0.1.0.1. Und daraus kann ich jetzt irgendwie, genauso wie ich eine LED dann in einem bestimmten Muster blinken lassen würde, kann ich da jetzt mein eigenes Protokoll, meine eigene Sprache drüber fahren und kann damit bestimmte Geräte ansteuern, die auch in dieser Sprache sprechen.
Aber das ist eigentlich, da entwerfe ich selber komplett was.
Ja, oder wenn wir jetzt diesen Funkship, mit dem ich die Funksteckdosen gesteuert habe, zum Beispiel nehmen, der spricht ein ganz bestimmtes Protokoll, also eine ganz bestimmte Sprache, namens SPI. Entsprechend muss ich die GPIOs dann in diesem Protokoll ein- und ausschalten. Und da drin dann meine Daten einbinden.
Ich würde das vielleicht noch ein bisschen versuchen, einfach zu erklären. Also du hast bei den Steckdosen-Leisten, hast du halt, wie Mirko vorhin sagte, du kannst zwei hoch zehn Steckdosen einsprechen. Das heißt, jede Steckdose hat eine eigene Adresse. Diese Adresse wird halt in dem Umschalten von Nullen und Einzen repräsentiert. Das heißt, wenn du dir den Stream anguckst, wie halt Mirko sagt, schalte auch mal diese Steckdose ein, dann siehst du irgendwann 010101, was halt repräsentativ für die 23 steht. Und die 23 sagt halt, 23 Steckdosenleiste ist eingeschaltet. Und genau diese Umwandlung von diesen Nullen und Einzen in halt irgendwas Sinnvolles, wie zum Beispiel die Adresse für die Steckdosenleiste, das macht ja der Logic Analyzer bzw. die Hoffnung davon.
Das sind die einfachen Dinge, kann man so sagen. Wie ist das jetzt eigentlich? Ich stelle mir jetzt vor, auf der anderen Seite braucht man da auch irgendwas. Also wenn jetzt immer sagt, man arbeitet mit diesem Gerät und man findet da irgendwie raus, was die reden und sowas, braucht man da nicht irgendwie so bestimmte Programme auf dem eigenen Rechner, die dann mit diesen anderen Geräten dann wiederum sprechen können? Das verstehe ich ja noch nicht so ganz, dieses Sagen, wie dieses Sprechen mit der Hardware, die ich jetzt, wo ich irgendwas dran geloten habe, funktioniert.
Also wenn du rausgefunden hast, was da mit dir redet, also ob es SPI, I2C, eine Serie L oder was auch immer ist, dann kommt natürlich der nächste Schritt, mit dem Gerät reden. Also bei einer Serie L ist das relativ einfach. Da ist seit am Beginn der Computerzeit das passende Tool auf deinem Rechner drauf, also irgendein Terminal halt. Wenn du zum Beispiel per SPI mit einem Flash reden möchtest, mit einem Speicher, dann gibt es zum Beispiel das schöne Tool Flash ROM, was dann für dich die gesamte Kommunikation per SPI übernimmt, nachdem du ihm halt gesagt hast, hier ist eine SPI Schnittstelle und schick mal da was hin oder hol da mal was ab, zum Beispiel.
Ich glaube, man muss noch unterscheiden, was man da jetzt an diese Pins hängt. Also ich kann zum Beispiel an eine serielle Schnittstelle meines Routers, mein Computer hängen, damit ich sehe, was der Router so über die serielle Schnittstelle schickt und mit dem Router kommunizieren. Anstatt meines Computers kann ich da aber auch, wie gesagt, andere Hardware ranhängen. Und das kann dieser Funkchip sein, das können LEDs sein, das kann alles Mögliche sein. Und dementsprechend muss ich halt wissen, wie diese Hardware angesteuert wird, um dann die Pins entsprechend ein- und ausschalten zu können.
Da muss man sich aber schon nochmal eine Weile einlesen, bevor man das so richtig macht.
Ich glaube, wenn du ein Bild hättest von so einem Logic Analyzer, würdest du es auch schneller verstehen.
Naja, ich kann mir das schon grob vorstellen, aber was ich jetzt mitgenommen habe, man kann durch die Arbeit in einem Logic Analyzer herausfinden, welche Sprache ein bestimmtes Gerät spricht. Und es gibt für viele dieser Sprachen, die gesprochen werden, auch eine Software zum eigenen Rechner, die man anschließend damit beschicken kann. Das muss man dann nicht mehr von Grund auf neu bauen.
Also zum Beispiel Modem. Früher, was Dennis von meinte, du musst ja mit deinem Computer auch irgendwie mit dem Modem reden. Das hast du ganz, ganz früher tatsächlich an die serielle Schnittstelle des Computers angeschlossen. In dem Modem ist ein Stein drin, der halt seriell gesprochen hat. Und dann halt dein Computer, hast du halt gesagt, jetzt fiel doch mal die 030... Und das wurde halt von deinem Computer diese Anweisung auf das Modem Übertrag. Und das Modem hat dann angefangen halt zu wählen und mit der Gegenstelle bei der Telekom zu reden.
Und wenn du da jetzt den Logic Analyzer zwischen hängst, dann würde der erkennen, aha, da wird ein serielles Protokoll rüber gesprochen. In der und der Baudrate, in der und der Konfiguration.
Und die Daten, die übertragen wurden, sind die telefonisch.
Genau, und dann würde er auf der Ebene darüber noch erkennen, welche Daten eigentlich übertragen werden. Und so wird Level für Level, wenn irgendwie diese Ebenen erkannt werden, dann halt das Versuch zu dekodieren und entsprechend erkannt, was darüber geht und dir das dann sehr einfach und convenient angezeigt, bis hin zu den Daten, die du eigentlich an das Modem schickst und bekommst.
Mich würde schon interessieren, wie jemand, der noch die was damit zu tun hatte, aber Bock darauf hat, das zu lernen, wie lange der dafür brauchen würde, um das wirklich sinnvoll einsetzen zu können.
Also es ist gar nicht so schwer. Also wenn du halt einen Logic Analyzer hast und irgendwie so eine Schnittstelle unbekannt und du was ran steckst und dann siehst du halt Flanken, Flanken, Flanken, Flanken, dann kannst du halt im Zweifelsfall im Internet gucken nach Encodierungsverfahren und dann zeigt dir die, also es gibt jetzt zwar ein paar, aber es sind jetzt irgendwie keine hunderte und dann siehst du halt, ah guck mal, das sieht irgendwie auf diesem Logic Analyzer genauso aus, wie dort im Hinterhand. Dann weißt du halt, ah das ist Manchester codiert, also die Codierung. Und dann weißt du halt, in Manchester werden Nullen so und Einsen so codiert und so arbeitest du dann praktisch immer einen Schritt weiter. Das ist tatsächlich nicht so schwierig. Also es macht natürlich Sinn, das mit jemandem zu machen, der das schon mal getan hat, weil der sagt dir irgendwie halt sofort, ah das ist Manchester und du musst halt nicht alle Entcodierungsverfahren dir die Bilder angucken, wie denn so die Requenzen dann aussehen. Aber im Zweifelsfall gibt es da sicherlich auch Bücher, die man lesen kann, die das erklären.
Um nochmal kurz auf das Manchester-Codierungsverfahren zurückzukommen, warum nicht einfach Nullen mit keiner Spannung und Einsen mit irgendeiner Spannung repräsentiert werden, kann sein, dass man zum Beispiel Störungen entgehen möchte und Signale doppelt codiert oder so codiert, dass bestimmte Bitflips, also dass zum Beispiel durch externe Umstände eine 1 zu einer 0 wird und 0 zu einer 1, erkannt werden und entsprechend korrigiert werden können.
Ach so, das heißt, wenn ich einen Logic-Analyzer ansetze oder wenn ich so ein Signal beobachte, dann ist sozusagen 0 ist kein Strom, 1 ist Strom, das ist sozusagen die einfachste Variante. Aber es gibt da noch verschiedene andere und die kann ein Logic-Analyzer sozusagen erkennen.
Wenn wir jetzt wieder zur Serielle kommen, dieses 8N1, was du kennst.
Nee, kenn ich nicht, aber ist ja klar.
Bei 8N1 heißt dieses N, heißt no parity. Man könnte es aber auch mit parity machen. Das heißt, es wird zusätzlich zu den 8 Bits, die in einen Byte übertragen, wird noch ein Parity-Bit gesetzt. Und wenn das nicht stimmt zu den 8 Bits von vorher, dann ist das Byte sozusagen die Informationen falsch angekommen.
Eine Prüf-Summe.
Eine Prüf-Summe, genau. Das ist halt nur ein Bit für 8 Bits, das ist relativ schlecht, aber es ist schon mal besser als nichts.
Ja, das heißt, wenn ich den Signalstrom nicht mehr angucke, da werden 9 Bits übertragen, aber die sind für mich eigentlich gar nicht von Relevanz, sondern für mich sind nur die ersten 8 relevant, weil das neunte ist sozusagen nur ein Check, sind diese 8 Bits.
Und jetzt für die Profis da draußen sind nicht 9 Bits, sondern sind 10, weil ist immer noch ein Stop-Bit dabei. Das heißt, es kommt grundsätzlich immer noch eine 1 hinten dran. Vielleicht auch eine 0. In dem Fall ist es mehr.
Die Hörer werden uns in den Kommentaren zu dieser Sendung sicherlich darauf hinweisen, wenn das falsch war. So, jetzt habt ihr ganz oft SPI gesagt, dass das irgendwie eine Programmiersprache ist. Ist das alles, was man dazu sagen muss? Gut.
Nein, das ist keine Programmiersprache.
Ach so. Sondern?
Es ist ein Protokoll, was über...
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einer Programmiersprache und einem Protokoll?
Beide sind Grammatiken.
Dann sag doch mal, was das heißt.
Okay, aber was ist es denn jetzt? Warum taucht das hier im Hardwarehacking auf?
Also SPI ist ein sehr einfaches Protokoll, was man über drei Pins steuern kann, über drei GPIOs zum Beispiel. Und das Tolle daran ist, dass ein Pin eine Clock ist und man kann selbst bestimmen, wie schnell die Daten übertragen werden. Das heißt, ich kann ganz langsam Daten übertragen oder ganz schnell. Das heißt, ich kann das mit sehr einfacher Hardware oder so, sehr performanter Hardware tun. Und letztendlich ist es der Gegenseite, die auch dieser Geschwindigkeit mitsprechen kann, dann egal.
Und das ist etwas, das wird halt oft verwendet. Und deswegen fällt das hier so oft oder ist das gerade Standard?
Genau. Also du hast eigentlich in fast allen Embedded-Devices oder selbst auch in kompletten Computern und so hast du halt auf dem Board gewisse Busse, die da eigentlich immer sind. Das sind halt irgendwelche seriellen Schnittstellen, weil die sind einfach fürs Debuggen toll und die sind sowieso in jedem Stein drin. Dann hast du meistens irgendwie I2C. Das ist ein noch einfacherer Bus als SPI. Darüber störst du halt ganz einfache Sachen an. Die Endpunkte dafür, die Steine dafür, kosten auch nahezu nichts. Das kannst du halt einfach im Sendbereich aus Board streuseln.
Sendsohren zum Beispiel.
Genau, Sendsohren zum Beispiel. Und SPI nimmst du zum Beispiel in so WLAN-Routern. Die Firmware davon steckt dir in einem Stückchen Speicher und das ist meistens über SPI angebunden, weil das halt, wie Mirko schon sagt, mit drei Lanes ziemlich einfach zu verlegen auf dem Board ist. Wenn du dir jetzt was moderneres anguckst, so PCI Express, was man von seiner Grafikkarte vielleicht kennt, das sind ja immer unendlich viele Pins da unten. Das ist dementsprechend auch sehr aufwendig zu verlegen. Machst du jetzt vielleicht nicht in einem WLAN-Router, um 4 MB Speicher anzubinden, könnte man, aber macht halt keiner.
Oder für einen Temperatursensor oder so. Da braucht man keinen PCI Express.
Aber das ist sozusagen eine von den Sachen, mit denen man sich wahrscheinlich früher oder später beschäftigen wird, wenn man mit Hardwarehacking anfängt. Also für mich fühlt sich das gerade an, als ob die Route ist, du schraubst das Gerät auf, dann guckst du mit dem Multimeter, Oszilloskop und Logic Analyzer nach, was da gesprochen wird. Du findest dann die Stelle, wo Daten rauskommen. Und da liegt dann relativ wahrscheinlich ein SPI an. Das heißt, wenn man sich dann mit diesem Protokoll beschäftigt hat, dann ist man schon sehr weit vorne bei vielen Geräten. Das ist quasi einer dieser Standards. Jetzt steht hier was von einem Buspiraten bei SPI. Was ist dein Buspirat? Ich möchte auch ein Buspirat haben. Was ist der Buspirat?
Wenn die S-Bahn mal auf elektronische Tickets umsteigt, ist das wahrscheinlich möglich, dass du das damit tun kannst. Der Buspirat ist einfach einer von sehr vielen kleinen Platinchen, die du im Internet findest. Das Problem ist halt, das ist ein Stückchen Kabel.
Ich weiß aber, gehört das zum Buspiraten?
Ja, das gehört auch zum Buspiraten.
Wir sehen hier sozusagen ein vielfarbiges Regenbogen-farbiges Kabel. Da ist an der einen Seite ein Stecker, an der anderen Seite ganz viele Pins.
Ja, also der Bus-Pirate ist einfach ein kleines Device, mit dem man mit sehr vielen 1, 2 und 4 Wire-Bussen reden kann. Also I2C, SPI und so weiter, weil dein Computer hat halt so einen Anschluss zumindest nicht rausgeführt. Und wenn du das dann anschließen möchtest, also du möchtest mit deinem Laptop zum Beispiel mit dem SPI-Bus von irgendeinem kleinen Gerät reden, dann steckst du den Bus-Pirate per USB an deinen Rechner. Steckst den per USB an deinen Rechner. Und an die andere Seite, an diesen Pinheader da, steckst du dann die Kabel, die zu dem Gerät führen, mit dem du kommunizieren möchtest.
Das ist also extra dafür gemacht sozusagen, um dieses, ich muss mir jetzt nicht irgendwie Beinchen extra anlöten, sondern ich kann hier diese, das sieht aus wie so kleine Klemmen, kann ich sozusagen damit am Board an die passenden Punkte gehen.
Genau. Kann dann automatisch damit reden. Der Bus Pirate ist halt das Schöne daran, du kannst ihm halt sagen, verhalte dich mal wie ein SPI Interface oder verhalte dich mal wie ein I2C Interface. Du brauchst halt für diese ganzen Busse, die es so gibt, nicht für jedes ein eigenes Interface, sondern der kann die ganzen gängigen, der halt alle. Und es ist eine, ich finde es ganz nette Hardware, sie kostet auch relativ wenig Geld, kann man sehr viel Spaß mit haben.
Das faszinierend ist ja wirklich dieses Ding, womit man das am Board festmacht. Das ist so, das ist wie eine Spritze, wenn man es runter zieht, dann kommt so ein kleiner Haken raus, so eine kleine Zange, und damit kann man es anscheinend an diesen millimeterdünnen Beinchen auf einem Board irgendwie festmachen.
Wobei der Guz-Pilot eigentlich wiegt es schon sehr fast zu groß für das meiste.
Okay, wieso?
Weil wenn der den Nachbarn berührt, dann hast du halt einen Kurzschluss, deswegen muss man da schon sehr aufpassen.
Das sind ja nur diese Klemmerchen, die der Chinamann dabei gepackt hat, da kannst du ja auch dünnere Spitzen oder ein bisschen Fädeldraht dran machen.
So, haben wir jetzt die Werkzeuge durch eigentlich? Also hier steht noch was von Minicom, Pegelwandlern, U-Arts.
Der Pegelwandler ist im Bus-Pyrod auch mit eingebaut, ansonsten kennt man den zum Beispiel, so Datenkabel von Handys, moderne Geräte sprechen halt selten. Also die Serielle an deinem Rechner ist irgendwie sowas mit 8 Volt, und das haben die ganzen kleinen Boards nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, jetzt wird gefachsimpelt. Es gibt auf jeden Fall unterschiedliche Spannungen.
Jedenfalls ist der Logic Level, mit dem du mit den kleinen Geräten redest, selten der, den dein Computer hat. Und deswegen brauchst du halt einen Pegelwandler dazwischen, der dann auf den passenden Pegel wandelt.
Den FTDI-Chip von vorhin?
Zum Beispiel den FTDI-Chip, ja.
Wir sollten auf jeden Fall festhalten, dass die serielle Schnittstelle, von der wir die ganze Zeit geredet haben, an deinem Computer in aller Regel eine ganz andere ist, als die, die auf zum Beispiel Routern oder Kleinkomputern ist. Es ist keine ganz andere, es ist das selbe Protokoll, aber die serielle Schnittstelle namens RS232 an deinem Computer spricht von minus 20 bis plus 20 Volt. Und dein Router spricht dann halt, wie gesagt, von null bis fünf Volt. Und damit kannst du dir deinen Router ziemlich zerschießen.
Okay, das macht Sinn, da einen Pegelwandler dazwischen zu haben. Ich verstehe.
Damit es nicht raucht.
Das scheint mir überhaupt bei dieser ganzen Hardwarehacking-Geschichte ein wichtiges Kriterium zu sein, dass es nicht rauchen soll. Also ich will nicht sagen, ich habe jetzt gelernt, wie man Hardwarehacking macht. Aber ich habe eine grobe Idee, welche Begriffe ich nachschlagen muss. Hammer, ja, werde ich gleich ausprobieren nach der Sendung an unserem Sendequipment. Aber jetzt nochmal, wenn ich jetzt darauf Bock habe, wir haben am Anfang gesagt, wenn man anfangen will, Hardware zu hacken, dann kann man sich so einen Lötbausatz zum Beispiel kaufen und so was zusammenbauen. Jetzt habe ich aber diese ganzen Tools, die ihr gerade gesagt habt, das ist ja sozusagen an bestehender Hardware rumfrickeln. Wenn ich das jetzt machen will, wie fange ich da, wo am besten damit an? Zum Beispiel am liebsten wäre natürlich, wenn er sagte, benutze Geräte das und benutze Software-Suit das und das.
Dann sag mal, was du machen willst.
Du kannst es ja kombinieren. Du kannst dir zum Beispiel einen Pegelwandler löten. Dann hast du dir ein Werkzeug gebaut und gelötet. Das ist auch nicht schwierig. Da gibt es fertige Bausätze.
Aber dann hab ich ja schon wieder was gebaut. Ich will ja was sagen. Das finde ich ja dieses Spannende. Da kann ich auch den Reiz nachvollziehen. Ich möchte das Gerät und ich möchte mit dem Gerät etwas machen oder darüber etwas wissen, was eigentlich nicht vorgesehen ist. Mirko hat sehr viel über Route erzählt. Ist das sozusagen the way to go? Nimm doch mal deinen Router auseinander und bau eine Steckdose. Dieses Projekt, was du da gemacht hast, dieses irgendwie Funksteckdose im Baumarkt kaufen, dann Router so bauen, dass er den steuern kann. Meinst du, man könnte damit anfangen oder ist das schon eine Spur zu haben?
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen ein hoher Einstieg. Aber vielleicht kaufst du halt so ein Arduino-Bastelboard und da braucht man fast eigentlich gar keine Tools, weil das wäre bestimmt eine Menge beschrieben, da man aber grundsätzlich immer Fehler macht. Brauchst du halt einen Voltmeter, einen Lüttkolben und vielleicht, wenn du mit deinem Arduino richtig professionell backen willst, einen Auslöskop.
Was ist denn die Uhr?
Ja, ich... Ja, wie soll man sagen? Ich wollte mir mal eine eigene Uhr bauen. Und zwar, ich hatte so eine Uhr in so einem uralten Radiowecker und der hatte so eine Siebensegment-Anzeige. So richtig 30, 40 Jahre alt. Keine Ahnung. Sah aber immer gut aus, weil sieben Segment, war aber schön groß. Alle moderneren Dinger, die da so kamen, waren immer so LCD und die mussten beleuchtet sein. Und das LCD-Finish sieht auch einfach nicht gut aus. Ich wollte große Siebensegment-Anzeigen haben. Und dann dachte ich, ich baue mir so eine Uhr selber, wenn es so etwas nicht mehr gibt. Und habe mir das halt gebaut. Und zwar dann halt noch mit diesem Funkempfang DCF77, dass sie ihre Uhrzeit selber über... Genau. Und ich wollte das haben, einfach nur als Uhr. Kein Wecker, kein gar nichts. Sondern einfach nur sich selber einstellen und die Uhr anzeigen. Und ich hatte null Ahnung von nichts damals, also nicht viel. Und musste halt alles Mögliche rausfinden, was ich für Bausteine nehme. Und selbst was ich für Widerstände nehme, damit die LEDs nicht kaputt gehen, weil die sollen ja nicht 5 Volt kriegen, sondern kriegen ein bisschen weniger und so weiter und so fort. Und dann muss man sich halt da so einfummeln. Und dann ist es am besten noch gut, wenn man einen hat, den man fragen kann oder mehrere, damit man nicht einen allzu viel nervt. Und dann schlägt man halt sich so durch. Und ich habe mehrere Prototypen gebaut. Und auch mit einem Kumpel am Anfang zusammen, der das eigentlich eine Menge gemacht hat. Und dann habe ich halt immer mehr selber gemacht. Und dann kennt man immer mehr und kann immer größere Projekte wagen und so. Und so habe ich halt irgendwie angefangen. Und da brauchst du auch Lötkolben. Multimeter ist irgendwie das Wichtigste eigentlich.
Okay, jetzt habe ich noch eine Frage. Ihr seid ja gerne und schnell dabei, wenn jemand im Club kommt, wie seid ihr die Reparierer? Wenn jetzt jemand in dem Status ist, der sagt, ich würde das gerne mal ausprobieren. Aber du sagst ja auch die ganze Zeit, es ist immer gut, wenn man jemanden hat, der das kennt, kann man mit sowas irgendwie.
Na manchmal weiß man einfach gar nicht, was es für Möglichkeiten gibt, gerade als Anfänger. Und dann braucht man mal hier so einen erfahrenen Menschen, der sagt, hier, du baust das und das, guck doch mal, da gibt es folgenden Stein, der macht das für dich oder folgendes Tool oder folgende Software, die hilft dir dabei und dann kommst du gleich viel weiter.
Noch viel einfacher, das Gerät geht nicht mehr an. Dann kann man es auch erstmal aufschrauben und gucken, ob jetzt hinter dem Schalter z.B. genau Spannung ankommt oder so.
Die Frage, die ich stellen wollte, ist, kann so jemand, der jetzt die Sendung gehört, aber ich hab halt niemanden im sozialen Umfeld, kann er dann hierher kommen und nochmal gucken?
Das ist immer schwierig, weil da kommt immer eine Menge Leute, die man nicht weiß, wie ernst sie das meinen. Also wenn einer mit seinem großen Sack an Elektrobasselkram kommt und sagt, ich blicke da nicht durch und ich will, aber das ist ein bisschen ähnlich, wie die Leute, die reinkommen und sagen, sag mal, ihr seid doch hier so im Hacken und könnt ihr mal schnell das Hacken beibringen und dann senken wir schon alle den Kopf.
Ich meinte natürlich genau das nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn er sagen kann, ich habe mich die letzten drei Tage damit beschäftigt, habe versucht, es selber zu machen, bin so und so weit gekommen, aber jetzt hänge ich hier fest. So eine spezielle, genaue Frage stellen, dann auf jeden Fall immer, aber nicht hier einfach hinschmeißen und die macht auch mal für mich.
Wir haben jetzt auch seit mehreren Monaten jede Woche fast einen Gast, der sich eine alte Drum Machine als Bausatz zusammenbaut. Und der hat das halt auch, ja, 90% davon schafft er alleine, aber ab und zu fragt dann mal irgendjemand hier, wie löse ich denn das am besten? Und ich glaube, sowas geht eigentlich ziemlich gut. Hier wird dir niemand Händchen halten, aber wenn du eine Frage vernünftig formuliert bekommst, kriegst du für gewöhnlich auch eine vernünftige Antwort.
Und unser Chaos Communication Congress ist ja auch schon wieder sehr nah und da wird es auch wieder ganz viele Hardware-Bastler geben.
Und eventuell, ich glaube jetzt hier auf dem VOCFB, auf dem Vintage Computing Festival Berlin, da war ja auch so eine Reparaturecke, da saßen zwei, drei Leute, die sich sehr gut auskannten. Und dann konnten die Leute mit ihrer Vintage Hardware dahin kommen und sagen, hier guck mal, mein uraltes Kettenlaufwerk von 54 tut irgendwie nicht mehr und kannst du mal ein bisschen gucken und so. Und ich glaube, da wurden einige Sachen repariert, weil alte Sachen gehen ja doch auch immer irgendwie kaputt. Und wenn ich mich nicht recht täusche, dann ist da auch der Plan, das auf dem Chaos-Kongress jetzt zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr auch zu wiederholen.
Dazu kommen wir gleich zum Vintage Computing Festival. Noch sagen, hört die letzte Chaos-Radiosendung. Da ging es natürlich darum. Und wir spielen jetzt noch eine kleine Musik. Und dann haben wir noch eine halbe Stunde für Hardwarehacking. Die Musik kommt von Mr. Beep, Slowing Down the Chaos, ZX48. Das ist eigentlich ein schöner Titel für diese Sendung, Slowing Down the Chaos beim Chaosradio. So, Slowing Down the Chaos von Mr. B hier im Chaos Radio 206, wo wir jetzt schon eineinhalb Stunden über Hardwarehacking geredet haben. Und, also, wie soll ich sagen, man kann es wahrscheinlich nicht eins zu eins sofort nachmachen, aber es ist schon ein guter Einstieg, wenn man mal grob wissen will, worum es geht. Und wir haben noch ein schönes Beispiel, zu Hause der Berliner Chaos Computer Club hat hier noch ein schönes Beispiel. Und zwar hängt hier im Club so eine riesiges, ja so eine Infotafel, die aus vielen kleinen LEDs besteht, die aber irgendwie dann auch angesteuert werden. Also das ist anscheinend auch gehackt worden. Was ist da los?
Na, die hat der Annemar Margun vor vielen Jahren mal bei eBay gekauft, die Anzeige.
Sag mal erst mal, was das ist eigentlich, damit man sich...
Na, wir, manche sagen, es ist ein Flughafendisplay, aber ich glaube, unseres hier waren die auf einem Flughafen, das war ja so ein Vorführgerät, da stand da was von Vorführung in Saal 1 und so. Es war schon in die LEDs so eingebrannt. Also die sind schwächer an der Stelle, ist ein bisschen ausgelutscht. Aber es ist eine große Anzeige. Die kann auch in einem Flughafen gehangen haben, aber es wäre wahrscheinlich ein kleinerer Flughafen.
Könnt ihr euch auch angucken, der ist streaming.media.ccc.de. Was musste da gehackt werden? Ich denke, das schließt man wie ein Bildschirm an den Rechner an, und dann ist gut.
Na, da war halt, ist halt so ein kleiner Mikrocontroller drin gewesen. Und das hat ja erst mal so funktioniert, wie wir das bekommen haben. Aber es war halt zu langsam. Es konnte nur ASCII-Zeichen anzeigen und kein Video. Und es ist auch zu langsam einfach. Und es stand hier ein gefühltes Jahr in der Ecke und keiner hat sich mit beschäftigt. Alle Leute, die Ahnung hatten, haben sich nicht damit beschäftigt. Und irgendwie hatte ich Langeweile. Und ich glaube, es war auch zu der Zeit, wo ich mir endlich dann doch mal nach Jahrzehnten ein eigenes Multimeter gekauft habe. Und dachte ich jetzt, ich brauche irgendwas zum Hacken. Und wollte mal loslegen und habe mir halt ein so ein Modul da ausgebaut. Habe es mit nach Hause genommen und habe mich da stundenlang hingesetzt und habe halt die Leitung durchgepiept, von welchem Anschluss das zu welchem Beinchen geht. Und habe mir sozusagen den Schallplan so langsam nachgezeichnet. Habe mir besorgt, da sind so Maxim-Chips drin, so für LED-Ansteuerung. Habe geguckt, was das für einer ist und wie die funktionieren und worum welche Beinchen wir ankommen, welche Leitungen. Und habe halt langsam rausgefunden, wie es funktioniert. Und habe dann, glaube ich, auch in der Zeit so einen kleinen Arduino gehabt.
Was ist das eigentlich?
Das ist auch so ein kleiner Mikrocontroller, der ist gerade ganz angesagt. Damit kann man auch, gibt es schon so ein Fertig-IDEe, was man sich für seinen Rechner runterladen kann. Oder man kann ja auch selber mit seiner Softwareflasche, da kann man halt, da sind auch so diese sogenannten GPIOs drauf, also so Ein- und Ausgabeleitungen.
Das ist Kanze blinken lassen.
Kanze blinken lassen.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was auch so ein pädagogisches, also ist direkt dafür gemacht, dass man damit auch lernen kann.
Das hat eine Designhochschule ursprünglich losgetreten.
In Italien.
Genau, weil die das Problem hatten, dass diese Design-Studenten ja keine Technik-Studenten waren. Aber heute muss ja alles blinken. Und da haben sie halt versucht, etwas zu entwickeln, womit man möglichst leicht, ohne viel Programmierkenntnisse in einer sehr einfachen Sprache, Lämmchen blinken, kleine Mooteurchen bewegen kann. Also die haben den Chip nicht erfunden, aber die Entwicklungsumgebung dafür und das ganze Board halt.
Genau, das gibt es bis heute noch. Das ist auch so eine Art Standard. Das ist so ein bisschen nicht Raspberry Pi, aber deren Erfolg war dadurch, dass sie halt ganz viele davon gekauft haben. Und deswegen gibt es ganz viele Internetseiten, die sich damit beschäftigen und Aufsätze, sogenannte Shields anbieten. Und dann kann man da ganz viel mitmachen. Und jedenfalls so einen hatte ich, hab den dann halt an dieses Modul, was ich hatte, angeschlossen und hab halt so lange gebastelt und programmiert und gemessen und getan, bis ich halt selber geschafft hab, Daten in diese eine Leiste, die ich da mitgenommen hab, irgendwie reinzuschieben. Und als ich das dann hatte, dachte ich, okay, dann jetzt immer mehrere Leisten und dann mal alle Leisten. Und so habe ich mich langsam halt nach vorne gearbeitet. Und über die Jahre wurde es dann mal besser, besser, schneller, schneller. Und bis es halt heute so ist, wie es ist.
Jetzt kann man ja wirklich sagen, wie auf dem Flughafen schon diese Anzeigen, wo halt Abflug und Anflug angegeben werden. Aber man kann jetzt Videos draufgucken und das ging uns an.
Ja, das ging uns gar nicht. Da konnte man zugucken, wie die Zeichen so langsam ins Display geschoben wurden.
Also wirklich so wie früher so die Flap-Dinger, wo es halt wirklich alle paar Sekunden hat es mal irgendwie die Dings umgeschaltet. Und inzwischen ist es 50 Hertz Video.
Also wenn ihr Hardwarehacking anfangen könntet das eines sein, was dann später, wenn ihr richtig fit seid, an den Start kommen kann. So, jetzt haben wir noch so ein paar Sachen für Leute, die anfangen. Ich hab schon geklärt, wenn man eine konkrete Frage hat und schon auf dem halben Weg ist, da kann man noch gerne herkommen und mal gucken, ob jemand helfen kann. Aber jetzt zum Anfang. Habt ihr so ein paar Quellen gesammelt, wo ihr sagt, okay damit könnte man vielleicht an den Start gehen und mal so gucken, wie man ganz von vorne anfängt. Also so ein Arduino hab ich jetzt schon gehört, das kann man da schon auch machen oder so Bausätze zum Selberlöten kaufen. Was gibt es denn noch?
Also für die Inspiration gibt es da so eine Webseite, die Hardwarehacks sammelt, das ist hackaday.com und die listet immer mal wieder interessante Hardwarehacks auf, wo man als normalsterblicher Mensch eigentlich gar nicht drauf kommt, was man so mit welchen Geräten noch so anstellen kann. Und das ist da durchzuscrollen und sich das anzugucken, was da Leute gemacht haben.
Aber ist das eher so, guck mal hier, dass ihr geil ist oder auch so mit Anleitung?
Das ist dann immer so eine kurze Zusammenfassung und verweist dann meistens auf so Blogposts, wo die Leute, die das gemacht haben, beschreiben, wie sie darauf gekommen sind, was sie genau gemacht haben. Source Kurzverfügung stellen, Tools, die sie verwendet haben. Das ist schon meistens sehr elaboriert alles.
Also zum Beispiel der Roomba, dieser automatische Staubsauger, der halt irgendwie immer nur rechts rumfährt und die hätten halt gerne, dass er links rumfährt. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel irgendwie hier, du musst das und das machen und dann fährt er auch links rum.
Ja, es gibt ein tolles Buch. Hacking the Xbox heißt das von Bani Hung. Das ist jemand, der sich sehr viel mit Hardware beschäftigt. Und in diesem Buch hat er niedergelegt, wie er sich damals die erste Spielekonsole, diese Xbox, geschnappt hat und halt versucht hat, die zu hacken. Und als er damit angefangen hat, war er halt auch noch relativ unversiert und hat sich seine ganzen Tools nach und nach erarbeitet und selber entwickelt und erzählt halt, wie das alles so passiert ist. Es ist sehr schön zu lesen und gibt einem auf jeden Fall einen tollen Einblick in was man so machen kann und wie man so dahinter kommt, wie man selber dahinter kommt, wie was funktioniert.
Also auch so die Basics leider halt inzwischen auch schon wieder ein bisschen älter. Aber so wirklich die Grundlagen finden wir relativ.
Aber so eine Xbox zum Hacken ist ja dafür auch nicht mehr so teuer.
Genau, das Buch kann man auch kostenlos online beziehungsweise als E-Book lesen oder sicher halt kaufen. Gibt es auch hackingsxbox.com?
Ich erinnere mich noch, dass wir damals bei der PlayStation 1 tatsächlich von Hand einen Chip raufgelötet haben, um Homebrew Software laufen zu lassen.
Hast du das gemacht?
Ich glaube, ich habe es mal versucht. Es hat nicht geklappt und wir hatten an einem Freundeskreis sozusagen den Spezialexperten dafür. Wie ist denn das heute eigentlich? Spielt das bei Konsolen überhaupt noch eine Rolle? Weil ich habe das letzte Mal, als ich von einem Konsolenhack gehört habe, da war es auf einem Kongress für die Playstation 3 und da ging es irgendwie um Super-Kryptographie und weiß-der-geil-er-was.
Also wie ich vorhin auch schon meinte, die Hardwarehacking ist eigentlich die Vorstufe für Software. Heutzutage ist überall Software drin. Also in der Regel sind tatsächlich so Spielkonsolenhacks inzwischen größtenteils Software-Sachen.
Also die Xbox One zum Beispiel war, ich glaube, die erste Spielekonsole, die eigentlich ein ganz normaler Computer war. Da war ein x86er Prozessor drin, da lief ein Betriebssystem und entsprechend konnte man auf Software-Ebene da angreifen.
So, gibt es noch mehr Anlaufstellen für Neulinge?
Also die Betreiber der Hackaday-Seite veranstalten ein Event in München am 13. November und haben dazu die R-Verkreis, also die CCC-Ableger in ganz Deutschland eingeladen. Und da werden mit Sicherheit sehr interessante Projekte präsentiert.
Also Hackaday ist jetzt was Einmaliges oder ist das eine Veranstaltung, die häufiger stattfindet?
Also die kommen aus Amerika, dort gibt es das schon öfter. In Deutschland ist das glaube ich das erste Mal.
Ja, dann was vielleicht noch zu nennen wäre, wenn man sich erstmal so ganz grundlegend mit wie die ganzen Rechner und so funktionieren. Die Fiona, die neulich auch mal beim Chaos Radio dabei war, nee war sie nicht, sie war krank. Sie wollte dabei sein. Genau, die hat einen Podcast dazu, Noobcore heißt der, wo sie sehr einfach den Leuten erklärt, wie Computer funktionieren. Das ist sicherlich auch ein schöner Einstieg. Dann gibt es eine, naja, es ist eine Firma, Adafruit heißen sie, die machen sehr viele kleine Bausätze. Du fragst das ja früher nach Bausätzen und sie haben auch unter learn.adafruit.com sehr schön geschrieben How-To's, wie man sehr einfach Dinge machen kann und sehr schön erklärt, wie das alles funktioniert.
Okay, so das sind die Dinge, mit denen ihr euch beschäftigen könnt, wenn ihr das mal anfangen wollt. Bevor wir dann zu den Hausmeister-Reihen am Ende noch kommen, da gibt es noch so ein paar Termine zu kündigen. Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen, also zwei Fragen an jeden von euch noch mal. Das eine ist, was ist euer nächstes Projekt? Und das andere ist, was würdet ihr gerne mal sehen? Wo denkt ihr, da müsste eigentlich mal jemand?
Das nächste Hardware-Projekt? Weiß ich gerade gar nicht. André, erst mal zuerst, ich muss überlegen.
Ich muss auch überlegen.
Ist das sozusagen Hardwarehacking? Nichts, was man längerfristig plant? Dann fällt einem das Gerät auf den Fuß und denkt, jetzt könnte ich aber auch mal.
Eigentlich ist es genauso. Irgendwie macht das Gerät nicht genau das, was man möchte, oder zu wenig. Oder die Schmerzschwelle ist überschritten, wo man denkt, verdammt, jetzt kann ich das nicht mehr aussitzen. Sondern muss da mal Hand anlegen und versucht, die Situation zu verbessern.
Hardwarehacking im klassischen Sinne auch. Mein nächstes Projekt wird sich mit Fußfesseln beschäftigen. Also die Dinge, die die Gefangenen an den Fuß kriegen.
Hast du der Scheiß gemacht, Starbuck?
Ich hab tatsächlich keinen. Aber ich zück mir gerne mal die Sicherheit von ihm an. Wie hardwaremäßig sichergestellt wird, dass das nicht abgenommen werden kann. Was da so viel Hardware drin ist. Zum Beispiel ein GPS-Modul, ein GSM-Modul. Wie die miteinander kommunizieren und wann sie was tun.
Hast du schon eine Erschätzung, wie hoch der Verbrauch sein wird?
Das Problem ist, man kann sie tatsächlich nicht kaufen in Deutschland und auch in Amerika nicht. Sie werden halt verliehen an den Staat oder an die Gefängnisse. Alibaba hat sie im 5000er Stückzahl als kleinstes, glaube ich. Das heißt, wenn ich welche hab, dann hab ich genug. Okay, also die Beschaffung ist tatsächlich derzeit das Problem.
Crowdfunding für 5000 Fußwässer kaufen.
Ich versuche irgendwie halt mal so leihweise, beziehungsweise, ich geh mir immer so...
Könnten sie mir mal ein Muster schicken.
Genau, ein Muster.
Alle kleinen Kriminellen, die so ein Ding haben und sowieso auf der Flucht sind, die den abgemacht haben können, bitte mal hierher schicken.
Das wäre tatsächlich...
Oder einfach nachts um drei bei Starbuck klopfen, wenn sie noch am Fuß ist.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob ich das jetzt noch mal irgendwie kommentieren sollte.
Ja, es liegt momentan unten im Keller. Dieses Amazon Fire TV, so das Apple TV für die Nicht-Ei-Besitzer. Das ist in der europäischen Version leider momentan noch nicht rudbar oder hackbar. Und da sitzen wir gerade dran und schauen mal, was man da noch so machen kann.
Inwiefern was man da noch so machen kann?
Na ja, also genau das, was wir vorhin so angesprochen haben. Die Schnittstellen auf den Boards sind mittlerweile alle bekannt. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie man über eine der Schnittstellen dem Gerät andere Software zum Buten gibt, als es von Werk aus hatte, damit es das tut, was man will.
Und das macht man als hätt ich dann sagen, indem man sich irgendwie so Datenströme anguckt und sagt, da schick ich vielleicht noch mal ein umgekipptes Bit rein und dann ist das alles anders?
Hoffentlich muss es nicht so weit gehen. Der momentane Plan ist ein bisschen einfacher. Also diese auf der Platine von dem Board ist wiederum ein Flash-Speicher. In diesem Fall etwas, was so ähnlich funktioniert wie eine SD-Karte. Und die Hoffnung ist, mit diesem Flash-Speicher reden zu können, ohne ihn vorher von dem Board runterkratzen zu müssen, weil der leider außen keine Beinchen hat, wo man sich einfach dranhängen kann. Und wenn das klappt, dann kann man mit ihm halt reden, so ähnlich als wäre es eine SD-Karte. Und dann kann man einfach die Software reintun, die man da drin haben möchte. Zumindest so der Plan.
Ben, ist das so noch was?
Aber es kommt auf jeden Fall immer irgendwie was. Software machen wir ja auch noch. Da ist ja kein wirkliches Hardwarehacking. Da wird dann Strom angeschlossen und fertig.
Mirko, noch ganz kurz, du bist ja bei den Freifunkern auch. Du hast jetzt schon ganz viel von Rudern auch erzählt. Ist das auch irgendwie mit Antennenbau und sowas, ist das auch Hardwarehacking? Oder ist das eigentlich...
Oh ja, in der Tat. Aber...
Das fragst du mich jetzt fünf Minuten vorhin in der Sendung.
In der C-Base immer passiert in Berlin und Antennenbau ist so ein Voodoo-Thema. Weil man sieht einfach nicht, was da durch die Luft, was da über den Eta geht. Und man erinnert sich glaube ich noch, jeder hat es mal gemacht, irgendwie so eine Antenne in der Hand gehabt und versucht die so zu richten, dass irgendwie der Fernseh-Ampfang besser wurde. Und man kann halt nicht das Ganze als normaler Nutzer auf theoretischem Niveau nachzuvollziehen. Das ist einfach schlicht wett unmöglich. Also es gibt ja nicht einfach Tools, die man sich für wenig Geld kaufen kann, wo man dann sieht, in welche Richtung genau diese Wellen gehen und wo man die Antenne aufzustellen hat, wo man sie zu verbessern hat. Das ist alles irgendwie ein großes Trial and Error. Und das wurde exzessiv in der Seaways praktiziert und zum Optimum gebracht, sodass da Antennen gebaut wurden, womit man WLAN-Richtfunkstrecken von einem Bezirk in den nächsten gebaut hat. Das waren auch meine Volksgeschichten.
Aber das ist jetzt so, dass ihr da am Ende seid. Also da ist quasi jetzt das fertig und ihr habt für, wenn ihr irgendwo Antennen aufs Dach setzt, habt ihr dann halt auch schon fertige Baupläne zumindest. Tja, falls ihr noch was zu forschen habt, könnt ihr es gerne in die Kommentare zur Sendung schreiben. Wir sind ja glaube ich im Hardwarehacking auch durch. Ist der denn hier im Saal? Schreit jetzt gleich noch einer? Nein, ich möchte auch noch was sagen. Schreit der Saal?
Die schlafen alle schon.
Ich brauche das nächste Mal für so ein Tumbleweed-Geräusch für meine Soundkarte. So, es gibt aber noch ein paar Termine, die ihr ansagen wolltet. Also ich vermute zumindest mal, dass es am Ende des Jahres einen Kongress gibt.
Es gibt zum Ende des Jahres einen Kongress. Und zwar den 31. vom 26. Dezember bis zum 30. Dezember.
Vom 26.
Nicht 27.
Wir sind eher am 26.
Wenn Leute noch viel mithelfen wollen, dann kommen die schon einen Tag früher.
Also es geht am 27. Dezember geht der Kongress los. Und sozusagen alle, die früher da sind, die armen Schweine, die arbeiten müssen.
Und es wird eine Hardware- und Making-Track-Game, wo genau solche Hardware-Hacks präsentiert werden, auch auf dem Kongress. Und es wird eine Reihe von Workshops geben, wo man dann auch hands-on nachmachen, mitmachen kann, gezeigt bekommt, was alles so möglich ist und so weiter.
Okay, gibt es schon Tickets?
Nein, aber bald.
Gibt es genug Tickets?
Es gibt dieses Jahr genug Tickets.
Doch, doch, doch. Okay, sehr schön. Gibt es noch andere Dinge, die anzusagen sind? Ich lese hier noch etwas von einem Heidelberg.
Also es gibt, wie auch glaube ich fast alle letzten Jahre, die RGB 2R. Ich weiß nicht genau, was ist ausgesprochen. Doch, Root Gag Back to the Root. Also es ist ein Retro Gaming Event. Also sozusagen wie die Vintage Computing, halt bloß mit Spielen. Das heißt, da hast du einen alten C64 oder deinen Super NES oder noch viel ältere Hardware, so Pong und sowas. Und sie treffen sich in Heidelberg vom 31.10. bis 2.11. Und einfach mal nach RGB2R googeln und dann findet man die nötigen Informationen.
Und dann kommt FIF nach Berlin?
Das ist bald, das ist dieses Wochenende. Das ist jetzt sozusagen.
Also wenn die Sendung vorbei ist, dann geht's los. In der Tat, geht aber bis 2.11. Was ist FIF? Was machen die hier in Berlin? Was ist da los?
Das ist das Forum für InformatikerInnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Die machen eine Konferenz mit dem Titel Der Fall des Geheimen. Ein Blick unter den eigenen Teppich. Geht halt um das ganze Thema Whistle Blowing und verantwortungsvolle Umgang mit Wissen, glaube ich.
In inklusive mehrerer CCC Größen als Vortragender. Mit Organisatoren, glaube ich auch zumindest Unterstützer. F-I-F-F dort irgendwas auch einfach mal googeln.
Eintritt ist frei, Um-Anmeldung wird gebeten und das Ganze wird auch gestreamt werden. Also wer es nicht hinschafft, kann es auch von zu Hause angucken. Das ist in Berlin.
Du weißt nicht von wo der Stream kommt.
Schaut in das Internet, wir hören aus dem OF TU.
In der TU, ja, das ist ja noch präziser.
So, dann vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen an Dennis, Starbark, Peter, Mirko, Danimo, Wetter, die Shownotes, die auf dem Sofa sitzen und alle anderen, die mitgemacht haben. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ihr könnt diese Folge, wenn ihr sie gehört habt, gerne kommentieren, denn Applaus und Kommentare sind der Lohn des Künstlers. Chaosradio.ccc.de, da findet ihr alles. Falls ihr schon vergessen habt, wo ihr diesen Podcast runtergeladen habt, nachdem ihr ihn gehört habt. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich hab euch nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.